welcome back to Las Vegas now you can
find your inner Zen at the sacred Lounge
inside Area 15 here to tell us all about
the special classes being offered is the
founder of Yin City Maryland yeah wait
you have to tell me how to say your name
because you said it so cute earlier like
whoop there it is
there it is I love it I am so excited
about this special class tell us what's
being offered at area 15. that's
happening this weekend yes September 3rd
Labor Day weekend the sacred Lounge is
really an experience like any other it's
the first of its kind to be inside the
portal with state-of-the-art sound 360
degree projection maps and it's a
full-on immersion of mindfulness
movement guided meditation and specific
trainings to really elevate your wealth
and your relationships so you're getting
all of it in that time and we're looking
at some photos here I can't think of a
better place than Area 15 to experience
something like this and then we just saw
some drinks up there you guys have a fun
deal going on afterwards right yeah so
we really invite you to join us in the
sanctuary Eric did a great job of
curating a wellness cocktail mocktail
menu so no judgment come in have a drink
and really we really intentionally
create it so that the community can get
together people desire that yeah you
earn your drink and let's talk about it
is the class still available can people
purchase tickets and then once they get
their tickets how is the process do you
bring your own mat tell us all the
details yeah so we have our mats and we
also have journals available for our
purchase bring your own journal it's 33
dollars a ticket you still can purchase
a four pack for the end of the series
through October 15th at a special rate
and you don't need to attend all of them
just even one just say yes show up for
yourself do the inner work and be in
community well you're selling me on it
I'm really excited about it and I didn't
get the yoga pants and no shoes memo but
you look so cute we are actually going
to bring in one of our interns Caitlin
come on over here she's gonna to help
out with a demo I'm going to let you
kind of lead I will sit here and Admire
from afar so tell us how we're doing
today so we're just gonna go right in
you can go ahead and step with your feet
together and then roll the shoulders
back open up the chest chin comes up and
then as you exhale chin comes down
straighten the spine and then take a
step out hip with distance apart so I
always guide this for the whole body
we're releasing stress through the hips
so you rotate the shoulder blades back
open up the chest and then slowly gently
lift the hips forward and then all the
way to the side nice big thoracic
circles it's so yummy to do this work
because people come in and do yoga and
they have no idea that they're working
specific stressors to be released we
cleanse the body you can go the opposite
direction and when you do come to the
sacred Lounge it's again a training and
then the root of yoga is the connection
to self so we add the movement so you
can go ahead and bring your feet
together and our all experience levels
welcome or do you need to be at this
level you can be in advance and you can
be a newbie lots of newbies there and
I'll just guide you through our last
posture hands will come to the chest you
want to tuck your belly in Tuck the
booty in sit low in your chair and then
if you want even more you can lift your
toes off the floor and then hands come
forward and you can just gently pulse
down and exhale yes because when you
come to secret lounge you'll get a burn
because that's the science you actually
need to dance out move out the stress in
the body as well as connect to the self
I love that dance out move out find your
inners in it girl if she's working she's
got a little bit so really quickly if
you want to come check out the class
it's happening this Saturday September
13th 11 A.M to 12 30 and then join us
for mocktails cocktails after love it
thank you hi we are all yes then now
Rocky I'll send it over to you namaste